よっしゃらー
髪の毛もちょっと茶色っぽくなってきたんですけど今日はですねー
僕はねもうねぇ
暴挙に出ますよなんかもうイギリスへのでっかいショッピングセンターに売っている
チョコレートほとんど買ってきたんでしまうわけですね
チョコレートレビューにちょっと宣伝しようと思います
本当にもう何か
イギリスチョコレート図鑑動画みたいになってもう仕方ないとか僕を持ってるんで
まあ
変な動画だと思います4つだけでチョコレート一発目は
ん
いや
エアロですこれはもう多分知っていますよんでもあると思うんですけど
これは何味だそうです
よくわかんないです
あっ薄いなぁもう
まあ普通に潰れてるんじゃなくてお店一点をじっとがあったとかだったクランキーとか
クラン系
あとエアロとか何か日本でもビルやつ売ってるんですよ
それが果たして日本のチョコレートと足が同じかどうかっていうところが今回の一致
なるポイントだと思いますねー
早速
それを上げていきます
ファーマー水なく高度なまあ普通のチョコレートですね
間になってた7日本でもよく見る方はですね
なんでもないトレッタのなんかオレンジピール系ですね
求めて旅です
よくわかんないですだけど俺みかんのカートが食べる人とか食べやすいと思いますね僕
はあまり好きじゃないです
しばらくチョコレート続くんですけど
できるだけ短くするんでもパパっと見ちゃってくださいじゃ
ban
dea